the former president's influence on
republican voters was underscored once
again last night as several trump-backed
candidates won their primaries in
wisconsin minnesota connecticut and
vermont ed o'keefe is watching all these
results for us and he joins us now ed
good morning
good morning tony it was another good
night for candidates backed by the
former president in battleground
wisconsin trump's choice for governor
tim michaels who falsely claimed the
2020 election was rigged won the primary
over former lieutenant governor rebecca
kleefisch who had been backed by former
vice president mike pence michaels will
face incumbent tony evers in a battle
that could forever reshape elections in
the badger state in wisconsin's u.s
senate race lieutenant governor mandela
barnes won the democratic primary he
calls himself the other mandela and
would become the first black senator in
wisconsin if he wins he'll face off
against senator ron johnson considered
the most vulnerable senate republican on
the ballot this year and one of trump's
biggest supporters in washington state
another sign of the former president's
strength jamie herrera butler conceded
and will not be on the ballot in
november she was one of 10 house
republicans who voted to impeach the
former president after the january six
riots now seven of them have either
retired or lost their race with liz
cheney likely next on that list when she
faces wyoming primary voters next week
meanwhile in vermont becca ballant won
the democratic primary and could make
history on two fronts if she wins her
house race in november she will become
the first woman and the first openly gay
person to ever represent the green
mountain state in congress nate
ed thank you